we're now starting part two of the book
which is on matrices
uh the first part was on vectors the
third part
will be on least squares these are the
components of the subtitle of the book
okay so now we're going to talk about
matrices and we'll start
with just first just the basic notation
and nomenclature first
okay so a matrix is
it's a rectangular array of numbers um
written between square brackets now some
people also use
curved brackets uh so that's a that's a
variation that you will see sometimes
so this is what a matrix is it's a
square array
and we talk about its size or its
dimensions
and its dimensions are given by the
number of rows
by the number of columns so for example
this matrix right here has three rows
and four columns so we call that matrix
a three by four matrix
so that's that's how you would refer to
this it's a three by four matrix
um now the entries of a matrix these are
the numbers
inside uh inside the array um
these these are these are called entries
coefficients
or elements of the matrix right and you
refer to them
by their row and column index so the row
index is one
for this row the top row of numbers it's
2 here and it's like 3 here
and the column index is like 1 here you
know 2
3 4. that kind of thing that's that's
how that works
um oh i should mention that the indexes
start at
1. that's an important distinction
because in some
computer languages indexes start at zero
so but in standard mathematical notation
uh indexes for matrices for vectors and
matrices they're indexed
starting from 1. that's something to
remember
okay so if we refer to this matrix up
here as
b then b
i j refers to the ij
element uh i is almost always reserved
for row and j for column but that's just
uh that that's again just a
that's just a convention um and you'd
say that bij so for example in this
matrix if this is b then i could ask
what is b
2 3 well let's take a look
the 2 is the that's the row index
okay and the second is the column index
so we go to the second column and the
third row
and we get this number right here and so
this is minus
0.1 there you go so that is
that is the you'd call that the 2-3
entry of b
is minus .01 okay
now like vectors we have we have a
quality
between matrices and we overload the
symbol so there's no special symbol for
saying two matrices are equal it's the
same old equals
um and here's what it means for two
matrices to be equal the entry
first of all number one they must have
the same size that's the first part
and second of all the corresponding
entries must be the same
right so just like a vector okay
now matrices are classified according to
their shapes um
if you have an m by n matrix a and that
means that if you know a
has uh if here's a it means that
it's got m rows and n
columns so this is a our matrix i
haven't written out the entries but i'm
just showing you the side
the number of rows and columns okay now
the matrix is called
tall if it has more rows than columns
and
it's kind of obvious why it means that
if if if the
entries were you know took a constant
width then it would actually be
physically a taller
the symbol the way we described the
matrix write it down would be taller
it's wide if there are more columns
than there are rows and it's
square if there's an equal number of
columns and rows so i think these are
pretty well
these are pretty well standard standard
terms anyone
with any anybody in math or applied math
or any
any associated field like that would
understand uh these terms
so you have square tall and wide
now in fact uh you know vectors are
actually special cases of matrices so
let's see how that comes about um so
we're going to consider an
n by one matrix to be an n vector so
uh and and vice versa so if i show you
an n vector
you can think of it as an n by one
matrix n by one matrix means it simply
has
a single uh column that's all so for
example
if i write 2 minus 1 like that
and you say what's that you could say
well it's a it's a 2 vector
it is it's also a two by one matrix
because
it's got two rows and one column okay so
and we'll see that that doesn't uh
that's not going to cause any harm uh
we'll talk about that later
okay now even more extreme is a one by
one matrix we consider to be just a
number
that's the same as a one you know a one
vector is just a number we don't
distinguish
so we don't really distinguish for
example between uh
this right the one vector with
soul entering minus three and the number
minus three we just we don't distinguish
um okay now
you might ask what is a one by n matrix
so that's a
that's a super interesting thing it
looks like this right
so i have uh square brackets and i have
the numbers but they're in a row
not a column right so um so this
is a column vector and by the way we
also write it the alternative notation
is with commas
right right something like this okay
and so in this book and course we're
going to be very
very very strict about notation right so
you know that's a column vector uh you
can write it
this way or you can write it that way
this
is a row vector there are no commas
there are no semicolons or anything like
that
we just that that's what is you can't
put commas in here and say oh well gee
why
you know we're going to be very strict
about notation um
uh having said that um i should say
i'll give you another warning is that i
i very much
hope that you are following along the
material in this class
uh programming or you know just fiddling
around
in some in some computer language could
be julia
could be python could be matlab well it
could be a lot of different things right
you should be aware that in in all of
these languages
there is also there's a computer syntax
for writing matrices
and it's not exactly this so just be
aware that
you know you'll have to unfortunately
keep two notation systems in your mind
um if if you work with one computer
language i mean honestly if you work
with two computers you have to take
it's like you know whatever speaking uh
you know french and german
you have to keep uh you have to keep the
mathematical notation in mind and you
have to keep the computer
notation in line in in mind and you have
to have a little table that translates
between here's how you express a column
vector
in a matrix and a row vector
one very important thing is don't ever
confuse these two notations
right so if you're if you're doing or
writing math write math
if you're programming don't write math
besides your compiler or
parser is not going to accept it okay
but just be aware that there are two
syntaxes
where i'm showing you here the syntax
the standard
mathematical syntax okay so
please keep them separate um oh one
thing i should say is
that you know people you know once you
know a lot and you get familiar with all
these things
people do actually kind of don't
distinguish between row and column
vectors
okay no well okay i'm going to just go
ahead and say this that's bad
okay to not do that but nevertheless a
lot of people do that once you kind of
know your way around
for now and certainly for the entirety
of this course and this book
we will not be casual like that i wrote
this vector this thing is not the same
as that
this thing is a four vector period if
someone's
someone says column or row vector you'd
say it's a column vector but the default
vector is a column vector this is a row
vector
and it's not it's not the same as a
column vector like for example if i
asked you is this
equal to that the answer would be no um
and actually or it would be some worse
thing
like you know hey what are you doing you
cannot you cannot ask me if a one by
four matrix is equal to a four by one
matrix doesn't even make sense right
so it could be some instead of no it
could be some kind of nasty
like uh comment coming back like hey
you can't even they're an incomparable
something like that okay
all right so i just mentioned mentioned
that here
okay now if you have a a matrix
we can actually uh talk about its
columns and its rows and these are kind
of obvious concepts but let's let's and
this is very simple but we're going to
see it's going to be very powerful ideas
come from this
okay so now suppose i have an m by n
matrix
and the entries are going to be capital
a i j and that's for i
going from 1 to m they're m rows j going
from one to n because there's n columns
so the jth column of it
is this and what that means is i'm going
to give you all the rows
so you can see a1 down to am
that's the first index the row index and
the second index is always j
because it refers to the column and so
the jth column is this which is
that's an m vector because it gives you
all the entries in that column
the i row is a row vector and it's an n
row vector and it's all the entries in
the ith
row and so you can see here every one of
these number
the first index the row index is always
i and the second one goes from one to n
which is the width of the matrix
okay so that's a row vector now another
concept that comes up is a slice
and that's actually one of these
concepts that uh
actually originated in computer
languages and then made it back as
it made its way back into mathematics
okay so
and that's fine because they kind of go
back and forth like that
so here the colon notation p colon q
means the integers q q plus one q plus
two dot dot
up to q okay so that's what that means
so it's an in it's an index range i i
should add you know in programming
languages you have more sophisticated
things like you can say
p uh colon uh
two colon you know q in a computer
language
and that means all it means p p plus two
p plus four and so on so the second one
is called the stride
um and then until you get to q or less
than q
or something like that um okay
that's this we don't use so so this is
that's computer
notation uh but this we do use
uh is uh is so if this says please take
the between the p and q rows and and the
r
to s columns and so what you get is
exactly that that's a sub matrix of
a is what it's called we'll get to that
in a minute a sub matrix well we'll get
to that
okay now block matrices is like block
vectors
you can assemble matrices together to
make
a bigger matrix or another way to say it
is you can have a matrix whose entries
are matrices that's a very interesting
uh interpretation of it
so let's see what that means here's a
matrix a
equals b c d e now
if b c d e were numbers you would say
well that's a two by two matrix
it is so what we do is we call these uh
we're going to call these
we're going to call we this is a block
these are block uh
matrices and we're going to call these
sub matrices
uh or even literally you can even say
the submatrix entries of a
um now there are some rules here right
that if you look at a row uh this is a
block row
bc now for them to they have to have the
same height otherwise they can't go
together
uh and that means they have to have the
same height which is the number of
rows right so b and c have to have the
same number of rows
in addition like a column here's a
column c
stacked on top of e they have to have
the same width
and that that means they have to have
the same number of columns
c and e so that's the rule um so let's
do a
let's do an example here's b c
d and e and a couple of things to
mention is
if you like you could call b a row
vector or a 1 by 3 matrix
c you could simply call the number minus
one or you could call it a minus one
vector or the minus one one by one
matrix your choice
um and here's d uh that's a two by three
matrix and
e is a two vector or if you like a two
by one matrix
right so um okay so uh we're gonna form
this block matrix bc
d e and uh let's let's first
check that the rules work so the height
of b
here is one right so you can see that
here the height of c
is one so we're good on the top row the
bottom row d e d the height of d d
has two rows and e has two rows also so
the the second row has been audited from
the dimension point of view
um now let's take the first column
that's b stacked on top of d
and so b has is three wide it has three
columns
b columns are silly they're just numbers
but they're it's got three columns b
that's stacked on top of d and sure
enough d has got three columns so that's
cool
and then the final one is c stacked on
top of e c has one column e does two
we're cool okay and it's a big drum roll
it's not very exciting
uh this is the matrix obtained uh with
these block matrices
right so um so that that's the idea and
i could some yeah i could even hear i'll
even i'll even try to do this right and
let's see
i think i got it right there we go okay
so
i've partitioned it there by the way
sometimes when you have a block matrix
people will actually
draw a little that a little dotted or
dashed line inside the matrix
to show you the sub matrices that they
want to show you
so here you can see there's b c
d and e and everything is cool okay so
all languages for manipulating matrices
have methods for
constructing block matrices and by the
way and sort of the converse of that is
to extract the sub matrix
and that's slicing all all computer
languages and packages for manipulating
matrices will also have a mechanism and
syntax
for computing for extracting slices or
sub matrices
of matrices okay
now if you have a matrix it's
m by n
we can actually write it as a block
matrix
um where the blocks are actually just
the columns so we can and this will do
many many times so a
is when i write it this way notice that
that can
that it looks like if the a and a1
through a
n were numbers that would be a an n row
vector
but here they're actually columns oh
also i should say that
this matrix a could very well be tall
but visually when you
write it down this way it looks y but
that's another story
okay so here um
these are so a one here is the first
column
and they're m vectors because the height
of a is it's m by n
that means it has m rows so each of
these is an
m vector a 1 8 2 8. and in fact you
sometimes
in fact a matrix is often often very
sometimes it's just thought of as a
sequence of vectors of the same size of
course right
so and that's a very common use of a
matrix it's literally just to store a
sequence of vectors
um we'll see examples shortly all right
now i can also take a matrix and i can
decompose it as a block
uh a block this time i'm going to make
them the row
rows so here the the rows and i'm going
to call them b1 through bm now these are
row vectors
so b1 has a dimension which is
1 by n so these are 1 and
these are n row vectors the the b's
okay and we'll we'll see
several times that it's surprising but
simply going back to this interpretation
of what a matrix is is actually going to
be quite useful
in a lot of applications we're going to
see that
okay so let me just quick quickly give
you some examples you're going to see a
whole lot more
before the book is over but just to give
you a rough idea of like you know where
the matrices come up
here's a natural one is is an image
an image of course is chopped up into
pixels and so here you know here's your
image
and now this is a bit silly but here's a
here's a here's something which has
two by three pixels now that's
ridiculous because
you know uh most images are you know
hundreds of pixels vertical by hundreds
horizontal or thousands these days right
so
you would never have an image that has
you know two that has six pixels doesn't
make any sense
well but technically this is what it
looks like and then what you're doing
here is
you're simply giving the value uh in
here this is a grayscale or monochrome
image
and so what that means is it might go
from zero to one or a very common
scaling now for historical reasons is
zero to 255.
so okay anyway so that's the ideas is a
matrix could represent
uh an image a monochrome image
here's one from data um aij could be the
rainfall
in location i on day j
that's it so i have i'm interested in 10
locations and let's say a year so 365
days
then i would have a matrix which is 10
by 365 and it would that that would give
me the rainfall at my 10 locations
so it's going to have a height of 10 and
a width of 365. so it's going to give me
one year of rainfall data at 10
locations and
now what's interesting is whenever you
see a matrix like this in some practical
you should ask yourself
i mean immediately what do the rows and
columns mean
and it's not a big deal but it just
means you should be thinking about it so
let's see what this means
in this case so the let's talk about a
column
let's look at the 17th column
of this matrix a the rainfall matrix
what does it mean
well the sec the column index
indexes days in a year if the first one
is january 1st
then this is going to be january 17th so
the 17th column of this matrix of this
rainfall matrix
is a 10 vector and what it does is it
gives you the
rainfall in my 10 locations on january
17th that's it so so
you might even call it a it it's
actually the rainfall
in my 10 locations on a certain date
okay
let's look at the third row of this
matrix well that's a
that's a 365 row vector
okay and the third row the meaning of
that
is it's the third location let's say
that's palo alto so
it's palo alto and then you get the row
gives you the one year's worth of
rainfall
okay so that's what it means so a row
vector a row of this matrix you can
interpret as a
time series of rainfall
at a particular location which location
depends on the row
so that's the idea uh in palo alto
there'd be a lot of zeros in that
okay not so much in the rain forest but
in palo alto
that would be a sparse matrix okay
um here's a very common one is multiple
asset returns so here
i have a set of assets in fact the slang
for that we'll talk about this later is
called a universe of assets
right so um i would have let's say
you know n assets or something like that
um
and uh these could be stocks that you're
going to
invest in or the stocks that you might
invest something like that and then we'd
also have periods days
so this could be i could index a period
which could be trading days
right which are like typically monday to
friday something like that
not counting holidays right so you get
about 250
in a year but that's the idea so there
if i asked you for this matrix
um what is uh
what is the meaning of a column
uh it's super interesting here
columns are indexing uh the columns
are indexing the assets and the
row is indexing the time period or day
for example if we make it a day
doesn't have to be a day so for example
the third column of the matrix
r is the time series of the return
for the third asset very interesting you
could plot it it would make sense you
could look at it all sorts of stuff
okay let's talk about rows what is the
fourth
row of the matrix r well the fourth row
means that i is four throughout that row
and that means it's on the fourth
trading day it gives me
the returns of my entire universe that
would be the slang
of stocks right and it means that for
all
uh n stocks i i give you the return
right so that row might look like this
you know let's let's make it minus 0.02
uh 0.03
right uh and so on and what this would
mean
is the first asset on that on that
on that period had a negative two
percent return
the second asset that's that's here
that's here had a plus three percent
positive return and so on that's the
idea
okay um all right here's a
very common one um and it comes up
in uh data science statistics machine
learning and it's this
it's a feature matrix also just known as
a data matrix and we'll we'll say a
little bit more about that and you'll
see a whole lot of this later in the
class
so here the idea is you use a matrix to
store
uh the value of a bunch of features
for a whole bunch of entities entities
have other names like samples
examples or in specific context it could
be you know
a purchase or a customer or a student or
something like that
so but in general it's just an entity
and so here x i j is the value
of feature i for entity j so
in this case all you're doing is you're
writing you're you're thinking of the
matrix
in terms of its columns like this
and it would go like that okay
and these would be m that's m this would
be m vectors
and x one is the feature vector for
uh item one x two is the feature vector
for item
two and so on all of that is shoved
together in what's called a feature
matrix or a data matrix
um so that's the idea uh that that
that's the that's what this looks like
okay um
again i'll just show you some simple
examples and we're gonna see a whole lot
more later so
um a a graph or relation
actually can be encoded uh as a matrix
and that's
often useful so a relation is i have uh
let me tell you what a relation is i
have a finite number of objects i'm
gonna call them
one two three up to n um by the way they
could have other
names you know like ceo cio
you know head of sales i don't know this
this kind of stuff okay so
they don't but we're just gonna call
them one two three up to n
okay and a relation is a set of ordered
pairs among them okay so for example
this is this is you'll you'll recognize
that squiggly bracket
as defining a set and the entries of a
set
are given uh between the brackets with
comma between them so that's an
entry of the set that's the second entry
third um oh i should mention
sets don't have an order so
i shouldn't have said the second entry
well the second entry in our description
of the set
uh but a set doesn't have an order to
its entries to its elements
so here and the and the entries are
themselves pairs so here it's
it's one two uh one three two one
okay and that's that's that's what that
looks like
um and you know i could we can uh
you know it could this could be an
asymmetric social network
graph where one two means
one likes two there um
one three means one also likes three two
one means well two likes one okay so
it's mutual that's good
okay and you get the idea so this is the
this is a type of thing a relation uh
would would um would encode
okay uh these could be for example a
bunch of web pages
and the the objects would be web pages
and
these could say this could say that web
page let's say two
links to web page one that's what it
means it means that it's it's a
it's a link to okay for example that's
for example um
okay now a lot of times people will
write a relation
as a as a visualize it as a directed
graph
and a graph if you haven't seen this
before
uh i hope you'll see it again in other
classes but maybe you
you haven't but i'll i'll just and i'll
be very informal here but
a graph i think you think of the objects
as uh these are called
vertices or nodes it's just yeah
it's it's vertices or nodes in a graph
um
then the rel the the actual uh
relations between here are denoted with
an arrow
and so here what we're doing is we're
we're drawing an arrow
so you draw an arrow uh if you have a
here let's look at one
here's something it says four comma one
and we're interpreting that to mean that
there's an arrow from one to four note
it's kind of backwards you might think
it would be four to one
but we're going to write it one to four
by the way people use both
uh definitions of that okay so
so every every one of these blue arrows
is is one of these things here and we
can just do an audit let's find three
four well that represents something you
know an
arrow going from four to three and let's
check it oh it's right here there you go
it's it's this one right here
okay that's the that's that one okay so
this is the idea of course this is very
abstract now but when any application
this it's actually kind of in it'll
actually be kind of interesting to see
see it'll be more clear what all this
means okay
so the connection to matrices is this is
we can write a graph
or matrix uh we can write a graph as a
matrix that's a very common way to
describe it
whose entries are either zero or one and
what we do is we say aij is zero
if i j is in the relation meaning if you
have an
edge from j to i
in the graph we put a 1 there and so
this this relation and this graph
and this matrix all describe the same
relation or graph or matrix or whatever
so
um and we can check um here
let's let's see what is this what does
that mean well
that's the three four entry
and so that corresponds to this in this
this this element right here
and it's and it's a oh and it's the same
as this one that edge so
this number this edge and that entry of
the relation
are all the same i mean they represent
exactly the same thing let's check
another one
how about zero that is the four two
entry of the matrix a so it's zero and
that means
there is no uh there is no edge uh
from two to four right or it says that 4
2 the pair 4 2 does not appear in r and
you can look here and you will see
indeed 4 2 does not appear
you know visually in the graph it says
that there is not an edge from 4 to 2.
let's see if i get that right from two
to four i switched them around
um and indeed there is not an edge from
two to four there is one from four to
two but not two to four
um okay so this is just an example so
you know matrix can also represent a
graph or relation and we'll we'll see
plenty of that in the sequel
all right i'm going to mention uh some
special matrices now uh this is you know
not unlike the zero matrix
the zeros vector the ones vector the uh
the uh ident the the the um
zero one and the unit vectors right so
there's some analogs of that in matrices
and we'll just get that out of the way
right now
um so if you have a matrix and all the
entries are zero
it's written as zero and sometimes you
you can put a subscript below it
if you want to let somebody know what
the size is right
otherwise you just write it as zero so
same way we write zero vector
so this is highly overloaded notation
it means that when you have zero it
either means
um it either you know it could be the
zero number
it could be the zero vector or it could
be the zero matrix it's your job
to find out which is meant okay
so that's that's kind of the idea okay
an identity matrix that's something uh
that
you don't there's no analog of that for
for vectors
here's what it is it's a matrix it must
be
square number one and then it's diagonal
entries
that's the entries here where the row
and column index are equal
they're one and the off diagonal entries
those are the
those are the the entries where i is not
equal to j
are zero so this is an identity matrix
uh an identity two by two matrix and
that's an identity
four by four matrix right and this is
also just written as
i that's pretty universal actually
notation so if you just walk into the
math department and say i
okay but you may have to say something
about the context of matrices
and then there will be absolutely no uh
no just
no everyone will understand what you're
talking about just the identity matrix
okay now like vectors we have a concept
of a sparse matrix and as far as matrix
is one where a lot of entries are zero
um we've already seen two here's the
sparsest matrix there could possibly be
the zero matrix because all entries are
zero the identity is sparse because
you know only the diagonal out of n
squared total entries
you only have n which are non-zero
and the idea is like vectors if you have
a sparse matrix
they can be stored uh more efficiently
and they can be manipulated uh
more efficiently now we haven't actually
seen anything you can do with matrices
yet but we're going to
and all of those operations can be done
more efficiently when the matrix is
sparse
okay so this is the these are just some
quick
ideas of of matrices
we have diagonal and triangular matrices
right so again these are these are not
things you you don't have no analog of
this for
uh vectors right so um so a diagonal
matrix
is a square matrix um which
with for which a i j is 0 for i not
equal to j
and that means simply that
that if your row and column index are
different
you the entry is zero and so here's
that's a diagonal matrix right there
okay that's an example and you can see
you know here are the
the ones this is referred to as the
diagonal of the matrix it's where i
equals j
and then these this is referred to these
entries are
part of the off diagonal and off
diagonal just means
i is not equal to j okay so
we have a notation uh if you have diag
of a1 through a n and these are numbers
uh then that's a diagonal matrix with
those entries
so here that in that notation diagonal
0.2 minus point minus 3 1.2 would be
this 3 by 3 matrix
okay so that's the the diagonal i should
say that
all all computer languages for
manipulating matrices
have something that will affect this
operator
diag it allows you to construct a
diagonal matrix
lower triangular matrix means that a i j
is 0 if i is less than j and so a lower
triangular matrix is going to look like
this
right it's going to have it's going to
it
it's going to have stuff on the diagonal
and and below
but everything above the diagonal is
going to be 0. okay so it's going to
look like that
here's a here's a lower triangular
matrix right there so
that's what we're trying to do here's
another lower triangular matrix zero
i mean fine it's lower triangular it's
also upper triangular by the way
um identity right is uh lower triangular
and upper triangular
um and in fact we can say the following
if a matrix
is lower triangular and upper triangular
it's diagonal
so that's that's the that that's sort of
the the idea behind this
um so here's an upper triangular matrix
as an example and here's a lower
triangular one
okay so yeah by the way not one bit of
this
should have any particular interest to
you yet okay so i'm just admitting that
right that we're just
we're just talking about the
nomenclature the the plumbing
you know we're gonna talk about things
like uh we'll see diagonal and
triangular matrix going to play an
important role
but for now this is just absolutely
you're just learning the basics of uh
you know how you refer to matrices and
things like that
um here's your first matrix operation uh
that's not true
we already had uh a couple we had uh you
can act
we we can actually form blocks so we
know how to
how to stack uh uh matrices
vertically and horizontally to create
blocks but here's our second one is
transpose
very important concept and what it is is
this i have an m by n matrix a
and if i put this superscript with a t
by the way not an accident that's the
same t that we use
in the inner product um not only that
if you will recall we were talking about
inner products i tried very hard but
failed and several times instead of
saying the inner product of a and b
i actually said a transpose b which is
what it is
but so i just the notation i shouldn't
have said it then because we had not yet
had the concept of transpose
but now we have it henceforth i can
refer to the
inner product as well we'll get to that
a transpose b
all right so but just just to let you
know you've seen that notation before
where it was completely mysterious and
now it's not and you know what the t is
now
in uh the in our notation for an inner
product it's the transpose
okay so it's this the transpose just
swaps the row in columns that's all it
does nothing else
so here's an example here's a matrix
it's three by two
it's it's entries are zero four seven
zero three one
if we transpose it you will see that for
example the first
column here zero seven three becomes now
the first row zero seven three
the second column four zero one becomes
the second row four zero one
or if you like the first row over here
becomes the first column however you
like so all a transpose does
is it swaps the rows and the columns
okay and of course if you
transpose a column vector you get a row
vector
and vice versa okay oh one
pretty obvious thing is a transposed
transpose is
a so if i take a matrix i transpose it
i transpose it a second time i get back
to the original matrix
okay so pretty straightforward
we also have addition subtraction and
scalar multiplication of
matrices so just like vectors uh that's
not an accident of course because
matrices generalize vectors right
because you can think of a vector as an
n vector as an n by one matrix so okay
so
uh like like vectors i can add two
matrices of the same size and i do it
just simply by adding the course
i just add the corresponding entries
subtraction is the same
scalar multiplication is the same i just
do it entry by entry
and there's a whole lot of obvious
properties um now
um you should probably you know make
sure you
understand these um we just don't you
can't just write these down
technically somebody should show that
that these things
hold right i mean it's incredibly boring
to do that but nevertheless
at the same time i don't know the right
way to do this but don't just look at it
go yeah cool whatever
so you need to you know need to sit down
and i you might want to verify one of
these i did
identities yourself okay so this would
say that
you know if i add two matrices then
multiply it by scalar that's the same as
multiplying
both of them by the same scalar and then
adding the matrices so
uh i could ask you a question like what
is that plus
and what is that plus well
that's the plus of two matrices so is
that
so that's the same i'm just saying at
the very least you want to go through
these and audit
every part of the equation left and
right hand side and make sure you know
what it's talking about is you know what
is everything is that an n vector is it
a matrix that kind of thing
okay um matrix norm
so like vectors uh we we have an idea of
the size of a matrix or
if you like the length or something like
that and it's going to be
the sum of the squares of the entries of
the matrix
um and then the square root so that's it
um people also sometimes talk about the
rms value of a matrix
and that would be uh that would be in
fact the norm
of a divided by square root m n
because mn is the number of entries here
and so that that would be the rms
value of the entries of a actually you
don't hear people talking about that too
much
um okay now when
the when a is
a vector we already have a definition of
the norm
but fortunately in that case they they
agree completely so that that works
and this would have the same norm
properties that norm of a vector had
right that if you
scale a matrix by a number uh and take
the norm
it's the same as multiplying the
absolute value by the norm um
and so on here's the that's the triangle
inequality
okay um and so on i these are
basically analogous to the vector one so
we're not gonna say anything
about that one cool thing is i now have
a distance between two matrices
so i can have a distance between which
is very cool
so uh i could do something like this
i could have the rainfall at 10
locations
over a year that's and i'd represent it
as a 10 by 365 matrix we talked about
that
so i could have a matrix a which is the
rainfall and a matrix b which is the
rainfall matrix they're probably not the
same i mean that would be pretty weird
if the exact
same amount of rain fell on every single
day
of two years in these all ten locations
that'd be crazy
but we can actually now talk about
things like in that case i can have a
minus b
um and take the norm of that and that's
going to give
that's something that tells me how close
where the two seasons of rainfall
so we at least we have a notion of a
distance between two matrices then um
one thing before we go on and i'm not
going to come back to this but i should
say
for well it's true for vectors as well
there are other norms of
vectors than the one we look at which is
the square root of the sum of the
squares
and there are other norms of a matrix
other than
the square root of the sum of the
squares of the entries but we're not
going to use those
in this book or this course but you
should know that there are other norms
and they're usually denoted by some kind
of mnemonic
i'll just tell you one just for fun so
here's one
uh there's this thing and that is
actually the sum
uh for over i and j
of the absolute value of a i
uh j there you go
there we go it's that okay and
so it's the sum of the absolute values
of the entries it's it's also clearly
kind of a measure of a size
it does satisfy all these properties
right
but we're not going to be using that
norm in this course you may use it in
other courses
in statistics machine learning other
areas you might end up using it so just
be aware that there
are other norms in which case the norm
we're talking about here
is called the frobenius norm that's
named after a mathematician named
forbinius
but but for here it's just going to be
it's just going to be
the um it's simply going to be we're
just going to call it the norm